to be loaded with 39 pounds a week has
been replaced by
a new card but some say these either
haven't arrived
don't work or don't have any money on
them sadia chowdhury reports
walter's lifeline came to a halt last
friday
escaping gang violence in central
america he's seeking asylum here in the
uk
and the home office gives him about 40
pounds a week on a prepaid card
to help pay for things like food
clothing and toiletries
but a recent change in the way the home
office issues these cards
has left walter and thousands of others
like him
without food for days we just try to
keep it for the baby
because with my wife like adults we
we know that we can support a little bit
more but with the babies different but
now that we don't have
not food it's really critical it's
really critical
because we don't know what else we can
do
it's the same story for this woman who
chose not to be named
she lives in a housing complex for
asylum seekers
where she says around 30 families have
yet to receive cards
it's a desperate situation i literally
thought of selling some of our clothes
since i'm not allowed to work i i
thought about selling some of our
clothes to to get some
some help until the the cart or the card
arrives
charities say a string of problems with
the new cards has left families hungry
now
for over a week the significance of the
problem is that they
only get 39 pounds 63 to live on a week
and that is such a tiny amount
and when you when you're on such a low
amount you know you're not making any
savings you don't have any backup it's
real hand-to-mouth so even being without
it for a couple of days was a big
problem being without it with a week
it's a disaster
i mean they don't people don't have food
we are signposting people
to food banks we're getting phone calls
from people who literally haven't eaten
you know it's really significant the
home office told us
those who have issues or are unsure how
they can activate their cards are able
to contact the 24 7
migrant help helpline accommodation
providers can facilitate
emergency cash payments in the meantime
walter says the helpline gave him no
assistance and he's been turned away by
charities inundated with requests
as an asylum seeker he's not allowed to
work while his claim is being considered
until his new card arrives walter has no
way to feed his family
sadia chowdhury sky news